you know do the ring
i would like to bring back no i will not
give you a drink no
i'm sorry i deserve to have this dream
i suffer too much you know natalie said
that's my ring
after all of this mess i paid for it
period as we know mike broke up with
natalie on the day of their wedding
now she's preparing for a long journey
back to ukraine
and for some reason mike felt like this
was the right time
to ask for the ring back to be real if
he didn't give it back to her in the
first place
neither of them would be in this
position so in my opinion
he should just let her have it the
interesting part about this episode
is that even when natalie left all roads
kept leading back to mike's house
in a minute you'll see exactly what i
mean by that
plus we're gonna talk about a couple
that i have never covered before
andrew and amira to be honest they've
never really peaked my interest until
now
i'll tell you why in just a few i really
did my best
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicia
let's go ahead and jump right in to mike
and natalie
today was supposed to be my wedding day
but it's not
after i realized that we're not getting
married
i couldn't stay in the house i couldn't
even look at michael also
me and i'll drive to seattle and stay in
mattel tonight
so i can fly to france tomorrow once she
gets to france
she said that she's going to try to find
a bus or train that will get her to
ukraine
now before natalie got in the car she
did give an apology to uncle beau for
the way she treated him at first
which i thought was really nice of her
but
the way she ended that conversation it
caught me a bit off guard
although it was very honest you're nice
man
i wish you all's the best oh lovely be
careful about turkey
i wish you a good stay and um
i'm sorry i will not keep in touch with
you i i'm sorry i'm okay why
huh i cannot all right okay
well have a nice life okay thank you
youtube
that's probably the first time i've ever
heard someone say have a nice life
and really mean it oh and then here
comes this creepy shot of mike standing
on the porch
i don't know why it looks creepy but it
does and you can tell he is stressed
he tried to apologize to natalie but of
course
she wasn't hearing it you're sending me
home during the corinthian and i get
sick thank you to you
what is your story i don't understand
sorry about everything okay find
american girl and be happy
okay i'm sorry i cannot contact you okay
so could you just go all the best
natalie might have thought that was the
last time she was going to see or talk
to mike
but then here comes an interesting turn
of events
here's the first one after natalie and
tamara hit the road to seattle
tamra got a text from mike saying that
he forgot to give her his credit card
for their hotel
the room is already paid for but once
they get there they have to show the
credit card for proof
so they turn around to go get the credit
card from mike
and that's when he brings up this damn
ring the ring that's been causing
trouble
since natalie threw it at him last
season
you know
no i will not give you a drink no i want
to keep it and
to remember how much pain it costed me
and how much suffering
i've been through i want to remember it
now
i personally wouldn't want to keep a
ring for that reason
i would be trying to get rid of
everything that brought negativity into
my life
especially if i'm trying to move forward
but
that's besides the point regardless of
why natalie wants to keep the ring
mike should just let her have it i mean
dude you caught off the wedding on the
day of the ceremony
that's the least you could do after
telling her that she was just going to
sell the ring
he asked her to get out the car so they
can talk and he also asked her for a hug
both of which she said no shortly after
she burst into tears and told tamara to
pull off
oh yeah by the way poor tamara this
woman was in the middle of all of this
well next week natalie and tamara
finally make it to seattle
but once again they have to turn around
and go back to mike's house
we have room reservation unfortunately i
can't take cards so i know the
you might have to go back to his house
i'm out of options first day of my life
we're here oh my god
what's happening here why is this
happening
is it all by chance or what y'all
if these rumors are true that they
eventually got married
after all of this i wouldn't know what
to say
we just had to wait and find out but
this this is pretty wild
let me know what you think all right i
don't know what's up with men this
episode
asking for rings back but andrew did the
same thing to amira
and this comes after he literally had
her out here risking her life to see him
he was a good person my flight to the us
is in few hours and now andrew's telling
me
it's not working out between us
i don't know why she thought that all
the signs i saw
pointed to the fact that he's not but
before we get into why they split let me
give you a little backstory
andrew attempted to bring his french
fiance amira to the us
before that k-1 visa expired but
due to the coronavirus travel
restrictions they faced a lot of
complications
he first came up with the bright idea of
amira flying to mexico
and then entering the u.s from there
that didn't work
she ended up in a detention center for
three days
after that he pressured her into another
dangerous situation
by telling her to go to serbia and then
try from there to fly into the u.s
love had her so blind that she agreed
which leads us to where we are now
amir's 14-day quarantine in serbia is
over
but the night before she was supposed to
get on the plane she and andrew got into
it
the fight stemmed from a previous
conversation amira had with him
about not having kids until they're in a
good place in their relationship
andrew took that as a mirror saying he
is not fit to be a dad
which wasn't the case he's telling me
it's not working out between us we are
not on the same page
about having children i am so
hurt right now because andrew is the man
i want to spend my whole life with and
to be yelled at by him
and to get mean text messages by him
i am in shock right now he even tried to
manipulate the situation by texting her
a ticket to paris
saying that she has two choices to get
on a flight back to france
or a flight to america now this is a
woman
who has gone above and beyond during a
pandemic for him
and let's be clear a lot of women would
not have done what amira has done
and now he's sabotaging it because she
doesn't want to have kids immediately
i mean after this argument i see why she
doesn't
but i will say this andrew must have
some secret juice or
something that we don't know about
because after the fight
amira was still about to board the plane
to the united states
but thankfully her body stopped her i
checked my bag
and i got to the gate and then he calls
me
and he's telling me uh okay but i'm
still upset you know
you're gonna meet an angry fiancee i
have a panic attack
and i become so scared about andrew's
reaction
because it doesn't mean i don't love him
it's just
a panic attack telling me that i'm in
too much pain
i'm in too much pain so i don't get on
the plane to the u.s
she told andrew about her panic attack
expecting him to be concerned
but instead he asked for the ring back
that's when she decided to go home to
france meanwhile
andrew was in california beating himself
up for the whole ordeal
i think that i failed i think that i
i look sometimes you just have to accept
if it's not working
don't force it the two of them
definitely forced it and we see what
happened
all right well while that relationship
is over next week we have a few couples
making it official
hazel and tariq are getting married as
well as rebecca
and zead i'm sure you want to go through
with it
this isn't exactly how i thought i might
feel on our wedding day
i know rebecca is nervous
but i can't wait to see her guys i need
to hurry and put the dress on what are
we doing
my dress does not fit where we go
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because as usual
we are covering it all i will see you
next time
you